m
vendredi 13 novembre collégiens chef
d'établissement cpe et parents étaient
réunis dans l'hémicycle du palais de la
source pour élire le nouveau bureau du
conseil départemental des jeunes une
instance essentielle qui permet aux
jeunes de s'impliquer fortement dans la
vie démocratique et de construire la
société de demain
en fait c'est représenter l'instance des
jeunes participer à tous les
événementiels parce qu'ils sont roque
aux codes sollicités et puis un côté de
saab à mener des actions avec des
partenaires donc il faut vraiment
s'investir s'impliquer et puis être
vraiment à l'aise devant un public
eve marolles présidente sortante et les
membres de son bureau ont présenté les
actions menées au cours de leur
mandature plus de 22 opérations un bilan
très actif pour cette année 2014 2015 au
conseil départemental des jeunes donc de
l'année 2014 2015 on a fait énormément
d'action donc avec les sans abri avec
les enfants malades je sais pas vous
tous vous donner ça va être vraiment
trop mais ce que je pourrais déjà dire
de cette année c'est qu'elle fut
vraiment intense on a fait des tas de
rencontre des élus des membres de la
police des associations et des jeunes
évidemment des collèges est juste un mot
c'est que c'était magique ou
et même merveilleux je dirais et voilà
c'est ce que je peux vous dire puis la
présentation des 13 candidats a été
lancé par evs marolles accompagné de
l'élu départemental en charge de
l'éducation
à l'issue du second tour jaton miettes
12 ans est élève au collège de
montgaillard est élu avec trente et une
fois sur 78 seront à ses côtés deux
vice-présidents swan gester du collège
saint-charles et ludovic babass du
collège leconte de lisle
ben déjà un grand honneur que mes jeunes
les minimes fasse confiance et aussi ça
me pour qu'ils ont confiance en moi
j'aimerais malibu le plus de projets
possibles et ça représente beaucoup de
bonheur et des heures j'ai passé une
merveilleuse amis et je pense que la
jeunesse lyonnaise mérite vraiment
quelqu'un de sérieux à la présidence et
je pense que je suis assez sérieuse pour
la réussite éducative et l'apprentissage
de la citoyenneté sont des priorités
pour la collectivité
le conseil départemental des jeunes est
un outil d'expression formidable donnant
l'opportunité de faire parler le coeur
et d'affiner la société réunionnaise